what would you see it's been the biggest
challenge with team its it like Jane
said it's hard being away from your
family and at the holy really hard and
then also sometimes like it's not an
invasion of your personal life that's
imposing your personalized on show it
gets going on but we have I think the
pros massively outweigh the cons not a
faint per se because I don't think any
one of us is in it for the same right
but the pros are being in abandoned
touring and get to release the music
that you love man the outweighs this
people the things I said about you in
the papers all them things kind of
irrelevant so how's the UK press been
harder you guys you know we're very
lucky
what does not mean anything that's been
like really bad like I actually think I
know I mean yeah there's been a couple
of hiccups and social media breakouts
like with you know other guerrilla our
fans against other fan bases and that's
been interesting but apart from that
yeah like James said we've been very
lucky I think we could we like to keep
ourselves to ourselves in a way quite
secret the way we go about our personal
life as well we keep that just to
ourselves so they can't really so let's
talk about your personal life but one of
the perks is your fans and your
grandmother's you must be seeing girls
all around the world because you can
you're traveling all the time certainly
my view nice right
really really has there been any crazy
stories on the road oh yeah with a
considered boys yeah
now we enjoy sword we like all I saw
together we like to celebrate you know
he's right way we do like to celebrate
we have some big night outs and when we
go hard we hard yeah I read yeah going
over here is good we enjoy life now you
are on a on a show and you went on a
durian 14 I think it's calling UK how is
the experience really good yet is the
most nerve-wracking feeling of everyone
but it was fun and I think it was
enjoyable because it shows that without
that season and the show itself is quite
famous in the UK I said ok and and it's
usually just members of the public but
then they decided to get a celebrity
Caesars for charity and I think it shows
a nice human side to like celebrities
because I think people are often like
celebrities will go on a date they
wouldn't do this and under they get
nervous or feel awkward and it's like
well people do and then also too and all
these big celebrities go on this day and
they have the hiccup in as a bit of
awkwardness and it's just I think it's
nice for the general public to see that
side of a celebrity so I eat they shy
around girls yeah oh yeah yeah because
of a pick-up line
oh girl you're not in song yeah no I
don't run this is right I don't exist
unless you've got a nice guy sorry my
god is ruin it's no good right about you
guys yeah
- you are you know you're not gonna you
gotta call person so I don't know I pick
up line Russia you look beautiful
oh it just not off someone how they are
yeah well how are you okay that's really
good that's a way to start conversation
so sorry you know what it's so great
about you guys is that the ability to
try new things and the facts you do so
many collaboration and you did with our
Canadian boy Sean vitoli we working with
him again hopefully yeah I think we'd
love to
we're very busy both of a circuit heart
but and when we bump into each other a
really good life yeah lady nice going
good musician and he's nice trying to
find out there it's been really nice for
us because we were on his first tour we
ever did and he's a simple in Austin
Island along soda and he she smashes
them grows and I yeah and he's a lovely
girl